most people buy supercars because
they're designed by trusted names
Ferrari Bugatti Lamborghini but for
customers who want the truly bespoke
service there aren't many options
available the compromise is often
between upgrading a mass-produced car to
a luxury standard or building a
handcrafted original lacking the safety
of an industrial batch one British
company says that's no longer the case a
number of people have seen us somebody
can actually take their dreams and do
something with it and almost design and
build what they want it doesn't just
have to be a car it can be thanks to
processes such as rapid prototyping 3d
design and laser manufacturing envisage
claim the ultimate motoring dream can
now become a reality and if you're
willing to spend a little more than
usual the buyer can work with the
designer on live sketches and then see
their - straight car in a 3d environment
their first customer wants to build a
classic car but wanting to rely on
really have to do is to accept it so
sage is gonna break down so I wanted to
create something that wouldn't break
down and was a genuine grant or
something you could drive out north of
Italy to the south of France with a
pretty girl
David Brown's feedback is in part based
on a Jaguar posing the question that if
you want a classic brand the Y trying
copy one haunting their wares at Monaco
stop marks Auto Show might suggest
envisage are confident there's a market
Tom Gibson Bloomberg